la vacunación contra el kobe 19 se está
tornando en un problema para los
franceses que están en el exterior
muchos tienen ya la pauta completa en
sus países de residencia pero sus
vacunas no son reconocidas por la
agencia europea del medicamento el
gobierno francés había prometido una
estrategia para inocular a los
expatriados con vacunas homologadas pero
la estrategia no ha llegado a si lo
hacía saber al gobierno la senadora de
los republicanos scheveningen o
garabedian el pasado 13 de julio
en enero de 2021 había sido anunciado un
plan de vacunación para los franceses en
el extranjero sin embargo francia no ha
enviado las dosis a los países en los
que no se ha comenzado una vacunación
con vacunas homologadas por ejemplo
argentina que vacuna con sputnik y
scinopharm
sino el mayor problema llegará en agosto
con la aplicación del pase sanitario que
instaurará un qr para las personas
vacunadas en francia o en otros países
de la unión europea para los casi 3
millones de expatriados por el momento
no hay solución para conseguir ese qr si
no han sido inmunizados con las vacunas
aceptadas por
agencia europea del medicamento la
propuesta para algunos debería pasar por
ampliar el reconocimiento de vacunas
la aplicación del pase sanitario debe
incluir completamente a los franceses en
el extranjero gobierno de francia es
hora de actuar para que francia
reconozca por completo las vacunas
aprobadas por la ms por el momento el
gobierno de manuel macro no ha dado una
respuesta a este caso